losing somebody that close to you um
changes i don't know i think people
could go different ways maybe they would
never want to like they would just build
a wall around them which maybe i did for
a long time but
also just being more willing to like
take that leap of faith
yeah
i'm ellie i'm 45 years old and i live in
seattle washington okay well ellie
you're a 90-day newbie so talk to me a
little bit about how you joined the show
what was that process like were you
already a fan i had to told
uh an employee about like you know after
coming back from colombia and then once
you know we were trying to like uh you
know do these the 90-day thing
and she was like you should be on a
90-day fiance and i was i was like what
is what is that i went on their website
and they were like taking applications
so i just sent one in
and really didn't think anything would
happen with it
right now
i'm a little bit scared about this um
how does victor feel about the world
seeing the ins and outs of your
relationship how did he feel about doing
the show um i mean when i told him about
it he
he'd never seen it before
or knew anything about it you know i
don't even think he really watches much
tv and
providencia
um so he was open about it and um now
he's not super excited
because he's kind of shy
and you know he's like i i don't want
people recognizing me and things like
that
so
we'll see how he um adjusts because
i told him oh there's nothing we can do
now i'm packing up my life and i'm
moving to providencia in one week the
biggest thing i'm giving up is my
restaurant
the restaurant is a big part of my
identity you owned your own restaurant
your own pizza restaurant for seven
years
what is it about victor that made you
say okay i'm gonna let go of this life
that i built for myself
and moved to colombia to be with him
what is it
um i mean it's a combination i did build
up that business and worked really hard
for it but at the same time you know
sometimes you just want to do something
different i think my relationship with
victor it's uh we actually we really do
love each other and we
you know
i don't know what how it's gonna come
out but
we really do like each other we like
being around each other we have a lot of
fun together
um so yeah i think we have a really good
relationship how did victor feel about
you giving up your restaurant was that
something he stood behind he was like
well you should hold on to it for a
while you know but um
you know he was supportive because we
had
like plans to do a lot of stuff down
there so we just basically we're ready
to start our life either like keep
living apart for what three more years
or just like take the jump when i was 28
years old i got married 11 months after
we got married
we went to atlanta which is where he was
from
i went to bed early that night and when
i woke up i discovered him and he was
dead you're losing somebody that close
to you um
changes i don't know i think people
could go different ways maybe they would
never want to like they would just build
a wall around them which maybe i did for
a long time but
also just being more willing to like
take that leap of faith um
because you just never know and like if
you think you found like the person you
want to be with then you're gonna try to
be with them you know because you don't
want to waste any time all the things
that you're doing to make this happen
is extreme and it's a little
crazy
it's hard for me to be like oh that
sounds great
because
of cheating because he was lying to you
yeah well let's talk about the big
elephant in the room that i'm sure a lot
of people are gonna have something to
say about
victor he cheated on you before um
he lied to you until you pulled out the
receipts and then he finally confessed
how have you managed to trust him again
after that is that just another leap of
faith you're taking
and it was definitely hard to trust him
but
i mean i really do feel like he was very
sorry about it um
and
you know i don't know
it was such a crazy time it was like
after covid nobody really knew what was
in store for the world for anything
not giving him an excuse but since then
i haven't had any reason to not trust
him
i mean
you know when we're together it's not
like he's trying to
sneak away from me and you know he's
always just like i just want to hang out
with you if he turns out to be someone
other than you think
how would how would you handle it have
you thought about that yet yeah i mean i
would just have to move on you know and
kind of uh
i've done it you know we've all done it
before so
yeah um but you know i
i i will cross that bridge if it comes
yeah i love your best friend by the way
she's a friend we all need that will
still love you but tell you the truth or
what she thinks is the truth oh yeah she
does know
yeah she's super cool
what does victor do for a living
in providencia
i mean before like the covid and the
hurricane he did like bartending
and playing music for tourists and and
locals on the island and
uh he's a barber kind of
you know whatever everyone on the island
just kind of does whatever well you know
90 day fans they are opinionated and
they are not afraid of sharing their
opinions have you mentally prepared
yourself for that yet
um
yeah well i mean i have read
you know from other people's shows or
whatever um comment sections
and uh yeah they're brutal so i'm
probably just gonna stay away from the
comments section
i think that'll be super helpful but i
probably actually don't know
how to prepare it's gonna be
learning as i go i think yeah have you
connected with any of the other 90-day
cast members or have they reached out to
you or anything um no not not at this
point
anything you're nervous to watch back or
you regret doing or what you would have
done differently
oh yeah
what what is that i mean there's just a
night that i we we got in a bit of a
fight and uh i'm definitely nervous to
watch that because i don't i don't know
how that's gonna come off
i'm probably gonna look a little crazy
[Music]